nominees for Best Performance by an  actress are Leslie Caron in the l-shaped  room for her adroit study of a girl in  technical difficulty  Shirley MacLaine in Hermel adduce who  allowed us a glimpse of The Late Late  Show in Paris  Madelene would in love with the proper  stranger didn't prove that it was a big  year for girls in technical difficulty  Patricia Neal in HUD for her portrayal  of the slovenly affectionate housekeeper  Rachel Roberts in this sporting life the  whole portrait of the request young  widow  and the winner Patricia Neal  accepting on behalf of Patricia Neal  Anabella  that was wonderful excuse solid being  with you tonight  you know she's expecting her first  fourth child in London but I know she's  very happy very proud very grateful she  thank you all all those things and a  very special one from Martin Drake and  for von Neumann  thank you all for her  you